it's i mean i was sick but i could have
gotten [ __ ]
i could have been dead
dead
yeah we'd be talking about me and norm
oh my god that killed me
did it
that killed me do you have a norm story
to talk about norm all day
one hit me the other day that
he was so fearless he didn't give a [ __ ]
who he pissed off or
i'm in the hall i got two good norm
stories good
you'll love this
so snl he would invite me every now and
then norm mcdonald passed away just last
week he was a good friend of all the
comics and
and revered
so anyway he used to
my
i know him since i'm a beginner
and
my first comedy club gig ever is
encapturizing star princeton
and norm mcdonald this is 1990 or 91.
norm's done a few uh
local talk shows in america small time
but he hasn't made it in america he's
kind of got a little following and
but now he's starting to headline in
america at comedy clubs
this is
at a time where
in new jersey if you weren't telling
dirty nursery rhymes wearing a leather
jacket you weren't really interesting to
anybody
but here's norm
this goofy canadian accent really
telling these long weird bits
for eight shows
and he probably bombed three out of
eight shows
whenever he killed which was he would
kill
when it was a sophisticated crowd he
would get him and he would kill
he would just go backstage he'd pull out
a deck of cards and he'd make me and
rich vos play poker with him
when he bombed
norm would go to the exit
and say goodbye to every single person
who left
just to be weird and make us laugh and
be awkward for the people and thank
everyone for coming after he died
he was such a nut
i love that
that's a committed person
i love but that's what i loved about he
was just grasping fame and figuring out
how to be who he to be different and
also one of the nicest most genuine
authentic people i've been watching over
and over again one of my favorite
moments of of his is
in 1998 in january so if you look it up
january 7th 1998 he did the letterman
show that is the day
that he got fired
from weekend update right and he
wouldn't say anything negative letterman
did many many times to him in his face
but he first of all he was fired he
still showed up and did this
appearance you know if you got fired off
your main event i doubt you would want
to promote it and be out in public right
and that's all they talked about and he
would not say you know uh
letterman was going what kind of idiot
would fire you know he's a very nice man
he was a nice man he just didn't like my
he would not
he would not be smirch the guy that made
it exactly the most classic
yeah
and it occurred to me and i was talking
to my buddies on a text chain the other
day a bunch of comics and i said
you know
this wasn't norm's time he didn't want
to live in a world of don olmeyers
everyone trying to cancel everybody
right you know
it was interesting that he's gone now
did you know he's sick i didn't know no
me either you said you had two stories
there was what's the other one oh so
he'd invite me over to snl
once in a while to play poker on off
nights on monday nights or something and
to watch him play poker while watching
monday night football at a baseball game
like he was a gambler right and
i guess somehow one time i found myself
on a tape night on a live snl i'm in the
hallway with a bunch of
pages writers
you know
basically plus ones filling out the
hallway i don't know if you you know i'm
sure you've been up there enough to know
that
where the reception is there's a lot of
hubbub right you can go to the dressing
rooms this way and to the right of the
studio and you know
makeup and it's a lot going on yeah
i believe rosie o'donnell was hosting
snl
and her very best friend penny marshall
was there to support her
penny marshall
at the height of her movie director
is
walking through the hallway
with her head down sunglasses on
baseball hat
doesn't want to be bothered
treating all these basically writers and
nbc
employees and me and
norm as big timing us
pretending we're just looking loose out
on the street
right just doing a celebrity
don't bother me moment fly by flyby
thank you
and norm picks up at it
and he just starts pointing and
screaming laverne
laverne
and she didn't look up she never knew it
was norm she's just gone
oh my gosh
and of course the whole always falling
down look i wonder if he's doing it now
oh there up there
wow those are great stories
[Music]